all the pomp of a new year's parade with
all the trappings of a pandemic as we
enter another year of covid the health
secretary today says fresh restrictions
are a last resort writing in the mail
sajid javid said hospitalizations are
inevitable but says he's determined that
we must give ourselves the best chance
of living alongside the virus and
avoiding strict measures in the future
what does that mean for me but for the
people who've been shielding the
messaging doesn't match the mood i think
we've got to the stage in the pandemic
where people need personal information
on their risk and benefit because at the
moment what we're doing is we're all
trying to work out for
ourselves especially people that are
shielding we haven't had the access to
our doctors what does living with this
disease for me mean and i think we need
to quantify that for people we need to
give people information
so that people
can can make decisions
about about keeping themselves safe and
and how they're going to live there and
how they're going to live their life the
health secretary today talked about the
three lines of defence he says we've
built up treatments like new antiviral
drugs that we know will help people who
have been shielding testing well we know
there have been some supply issues and
of course vaccines at places like this
the government say it's reached its
target of offering a jab to everyone by
today and as boosters drift into the new
year hospital admissions around half
where they were in january last year
we're going to come under much higher
pressure uh this year than we did last
january so it won't take 34 000 cases
for the nhs to come under real pressure
we got through by the skin of our teeth
last january but i think the numbers of
covered hospitalizations will be lower
than that before we come under
similar kinds of pressure
the limits of the nhs are already being
tested and living with covid some
believe could mean rethinking our
approach to things like testing the
tests were never designed to be used
with healthy or otherwise asymptomatic
adults
they're really a way of confirming what
infection you've got
and if you've got a respiratory
infection
then perhaps we just need to shift a
little bit our expectations and say well
you stay at home and you don't go out
and mix with other people
as a new year begins the government is
still waiting to see what impact
christmas has had on the spread but
their tone rightly or wrongly is
optimistic
ali fortescue sky news